[拍手]
まず私の紹介から始めたいと思います
ここに一つの前後が掲げてあります日日是好日と呼びまして前後ですので色々解釈は
あるんですがここにあるように日々色々なことたとえばいいこともあり悪いこともある
んですがそれも日々の努力で良い日に変えていこうというような言葉です
私はこの言葉
をとても大事にしておりまして日課というものを日々実践しております
まず会社に出社する前にですね自転車に乗って東京湾まで毎朝走って空の写真を撮ると
いうのは一つの日課にしています
また今日こんな格好してますけど家に仕事から帰ってくると家でお茶をたててその飛距
何が伴ってのお茶をたてながら楽しむというのを2つの日課としております
たまにやっても気付かないんですけど日課であると気づくことがあるんですね
この写真はですね東京なんですけど2月のとても寒い冬空なんですが
夜明け前の15分くらいのところですねこういうふうに紫色に光る費が1年に数字つ
だけあるんです
これやっぱり毎日あることによって気付いたことですねこれお茶も一緒です
毎日王者を立ってるとまぁ
わずかな抹茶の味の違いってのもそうなんですけど自分がこのお茶を点てるっていう
行為にもう少し変化があるわけです
皆様のですね仕事や趣味色々なものでですね日々やってれて体に馴染んでるからこそ
今日はちょっと違うなっていうわずかな気づくことがあるかと
そういうことを経験があるかなと思っています私はこの日課で習慣化しているからこそ
ほんのわずかなインサイト気づきに気付きそれを未来を予測することができるんじゃ
ないかと考えています
私は長野県の片田舎で生まれました
でこの写真にあるように盆と正月だけではなくて田植えの時も毎年帰って農業を手伝っ
ているわけですが
満天の星空が迎えてくれるわけですまあその星空が役に立ったのかわかりませんが
小さい頃から宇宙開発が好きで絶対家の仕事に就きたいなあと考えていました上京した
際に
ですねやっぱりその宇宙工学を学べる大学院に所属することができました
私が所属した頃の宇宙工学というのはですね
コンピューターを使った数値シミュレーションがシュシュでございまして
工学部などにものを作るってことがなかなかなかったんですね
その時にいい天気がありましてキューブサットプロジェクトっていうのが世界で
スタートしました
学生手作りで例えば我々であったら秋葉原から部品を集めてきて人口
名声をゼロから作ってみようという学生プロジェクトです世界中の大学が開発競争に
乗り出したわけですけど最初に開発にこぎつけたのが日本の東大と東工大のに大学でし
た
ってこういうチャンスに我々は巡り合いまして寄付さとは10センチ立法重さ1キロ
片手に乗るような超小型衛星ですこれをですね2003
年今からもう14年前になりますが実際のロシアのロケットを使って宇宙に打ち上げて
学生手作りで世界初の成功を収めました
このキューブサットというものはですね現在14年たって世界中の宇宙工学が宇宙を
学ぶと言うで教育プログラムとしてなっています
でこの2つの研究室はその後も衛星開発を続け7個の衛星開発に成功してを致しました
小さい頃から私も jaxa の宇宙機関で就職するというのが夢だったんですが
衛星をゼロから作れるんだなぁ会社を起業できるんじゃないかと考えたわけです
でまあ学生時代に学んだことは非常に多かったんですが一番重要なことはお金がなかっ
たことですね
やはりとても宇宙開発のお金がかかるんですけどお金がないところでものを作ったって
いうのはその後のコストパフォーマンスという意味で我々の強みになりました
ベンチャー企業ですから当然をお客さんがいないとビジネスは回らないわけです
いろんなお客さんにはレースで作れるんですけど sa 買いませんかと営業に回り
ました
なかなか厳しかったんですけど民間の気象会社さんが
を気象衛星を欲しいと言ってくれたわけですねそれまでのエースが最低でも100億円
定期とても高い sa が我々は2億円で作れたので100分の
1クラスの価格破壊を起こしたわけですこのためにこの我々の契約が6することができ
ました
じゃあこの民間の気象会社はどんなことに使いたかったらこの会で示していますが夏の
北極海は地球温暖化の影響で溶けて一部のこのヘリのところがですね船が通れるんです
ね
例えば横浜からロッテルダムにタンカーや貨物船で物を運ぶ際に普段は南回りなんです
が
夏の一部はですねこの北極海を通ることで3分の2にショートカットできますこれは後
から知ったことなんですが大きい単価は1日燃料代が数百万円もするらしくて
船会社としてはこの3分類のショートカットっていうのは大きな経費削減であるわけ
ですねその
民間の気象会社はこの北極海を衛星で関することによって船会社に最適な航路を提供
するというビジネスでした
このように衛星を作る技術は学生時代に学んでいたんですがこの北極海の話なんてのは
とても我々が思いつかなかったので我々の衛星を作ったことでいろんなもののお客さん
が増えてくるだろうと考えたわけです
創業して8年たっておりますがついに今年の4年4月にですね
日本橋に王室お引越してまいりました
最長3人で始めた会社も現在34人まで大きなり国籍も10カ国以上になっています
よくある質問に人工衛星はどこで作ってるんですか
工場はどっかにあるんですかって聞かれるわけですが我々は学生税ゼロから作った
ベースとなっている会社ですので
日本橋にクリーンルームを作って衛星を作っていますまつまり
メイドイン日本橋の衛星ですおそらく世界でもこんなに都会で作ってる衛星はないと
考えています
ありがとうございます
まあ創業以来さんこの人工衛星を打ち上げてまいりました
特に右側の衛星はですね先週の金曜日に打ち上がったばかりでございまして
ロシアのロケットを使ってこのロケットポケットの先に我々の衛星をくっつけて
打ち上げてきたわけです
ではこの衛星っていうのはどのような用途があるかっていうのを少し紹介したいと思い
ます
我々の2期目に挙げた衛星が宇宙から奪った日本橋の写真ですこのように宇宙から見る
と
ドローンによりも飛行距離ももっと
高いところから写真を撮ることができますつまりこの建物の状況などの経済状況が
わかるわけですね
これはマダカスカルの赤い土で構成された山から流れ出る川です
油絵のように見えますが実際に宇宙から見るとこのように見えるかはがあるわけですね
これはポリネシアというエリアでバリアリーフと呼ばれる綺麗なサンゴが構成されてい
ますご存知の通り世界中にサンゴが死ぬという現象が起こっていますのでまぁこの
サンゴの面積なども家
から見ることで確認することができます
これは結構面白いんですけどニュージーランドの火山なんですね
10キロにもあるきれいな森の神炎ができていますこれはなぜできているか調べてみ
たらですね火山が危ないのでか山から数キロまでは
た畑の開墾をしてはいけないって法律があるようなんですね人々はその法律ギリギリ
までた方を開墾して言ったらですね宇宙から見ると森が綺麗に新鋭になっていたとこう
いうお話です
これは
円形農場サウジアラビアの砂漠にできた人工的な農場です
直径一つ一つが1キロにもなる円形農場なんですが真ん中に軸があってそこから水を
まいてたねお前で刈り取るまで自動で行っている人口の農場です
このように農業の状況が宇宙からもすべてよく分かるということです
このように人工衛星の画像を使えば都市であったり農業であったりいろんな解析が
できる
つまりこういう写真を撮る衛星が次々とかいたいというお客さんが出てくるはずでした
しかしここに我々の発想の転換が必要でしたというのは衛星画像も欲しいけど
衛星を保有したくはないというお客さんが多かったんですね
そこでこれから紹介しますアクセルグローブで我々の2本目の軸を紹介したいと思い
ます
一つ動画を見てみますがここにちょうど2分の1の模型がありますがこれは我々が今
作っているグループと呼ばれる人工衛星の模型です
この衛星をですね我々が資金調達を頑張ってお金を集めで打ち上げてしまいます
衛星が地球の回る仮想的な性を起動音はられますがこの青い性が起動ですねそこに点々
が一つ一つのグルーすです
この50機をですね数珠繋ぎのように粉吹くように配置するわけですねそうするとこの
ように地球全体を写真で取り付くせるという地球全体をスキャンするというシステムが
完成します
これができあがりますとですね例えば農地に注目してみますと同じ地点をですね前に
撮影できるのでどの地点が今
活性化していて今仮時だとかそういう農業の最適ができるわけですね
全世界の第一を取ってますので当然のごとく
港も取れています例えばこれは東京版ですがこのコンテナーの数を数えることができ
ますので今このコンテナがどれだけ混んでるかということが予想できるんですね
例えばこの後港は混んでるのでちょっと違うコンテらーにーま違う皆トリマー村などの
ロジスティックの最適化ができるわけです
世界中の大地が毎日採れていますので
昨日なかったものが今日現れたとか2実こういうトレンドがあるからきっとこういう風
になるだろうみたいなあらゆることがこのデータから生まれるのではないかと考えてい
ます
これを日本初の日本橋初の衛星で実現したいと考えています
つまり50基の超小型衛星を打ち上げます先ほど言いましたように高性能な衛星を低
コスで打ち上げるのが我々の強みですのでこの50機を打ち上げることで地球全体を
毎日撮影しますつまり衛星画像のビッグデータを作るわけですこれを ai 技術を
使ってどんどん解析しようと考えています一つ一つの衛星画像を
このように毎日重ねていくことによりその変化を抽出していこうと考えているわけです
でこのアクセルグローブという計画50基を打ち上げていかなくちゃいけないわけです
が今年の冬から初期3基を打ち上げまして2022年までに50期待して地球を毎日
取れるっていう環境を実現したいと考えていますではこのアクセルグローブで何が
できるかっての一例を紹介します
まずはやはり農業ですね人間の目ではない特殊なカメラを積んでいますので左上のよう
に
農地が丸裸です例えば肥料がかてうっていう
投げられてやるっていうのも把握ができることになっています左のようにそれを毎日た
珍音れますのでこののうええのう今日の発育のトレンドがわかるわけですね右上ば東京
都東京版の画像です
先ほど ai とビッグデータというキーワードを使いましたがこれだけの大きい
データを
人間の目で見ることはほぼ不可能ですそれで我々は ai による自動解析も進めて
まして
この衛星画像某この2番目のギザギザの写真は海か
陸地化か分かってのを自動で判別していますこの中で海と判定した中に黄色い点が見え
ますが船を自動で計測していますつまりですね港の監視するというお客さんが入った時
に
衛星画像るんではなくて ai 出船おかずにして何席でしたというデータを売ると
いうビジネスモデルです
右下の画像は衛星画像から建物と道路自動で抽出している情報です
赤い部分が道になっておりまして青い部分が建物なっていますこれが毎日採れますので
建物が現れたとか
大きい建物であればどういう進捗になっているかというのが見えたりとか
例えば道路であればアフリカのようにま
ダッジ頭がない国もあるんですねそれが最新の地図が衛星画像から自動で作れるとか
例えば震災などがあった時にこの道は断絶して通れないなどの情報も中止することが
できます
あくまで今の例は一例です私の最初のところですね
日日是好日という言葉で日課でやるとですねわずかな変化がわかるという話をいたし
ました
例えばアクセルグローブに近いシステムとして気象衛星があります
気象衛星は地球の雲の画像を毎日撮影している訳ですけどその毎日の撮影の画像が何十
塩分も蓄積されていますその中で気象学という学問が生まれ
気象予報士っていう資格が生まれ気象予報士達は未来
そうです今までの蓄積を使って明日の天気がどうなるかという未来の予測ができてい
ます
逆せるグローブが完成しますと世界中の第一が前にデータとして蓄積されていきますの
で
例えば明日火山が噴火さ
いうかもしれないという火山予報士であったりとかあといけすとかですね養殖にだ甚大
な被害を与えるといわれる
私をの予想する明かし予報士っていういろんなものができるかなと考えております
まあ今我々はですねこのアクセルグローブっていうのは日々
早く皆様にお届けするように努力して開発をしているところであります
先ほどの証をの例で言いますと私が海を見てても多分わからないと思うんですね
赤潮の専門家が見たからこそこのわずかな変化を築いて明日大発生するだろうっていう
未来の予測ができていると思うんですね
ここに来ている皆さんもですねいろいろなフィールドをないろんなビジネスの方が
いらっしゃると思いますが毎日
地球の皆様のところが見れた時にですねあなたたちだけが分かる
は頭からインサイトがあると思うんですねそれを未来を予測するようなビジネスを考え
てそのアイデアをわれわれに教えていただきたいと思います
世界を毎日見て未来
を書いていこうありがとうございました
[拍手]